[Música]
el salvador se convierte hoy en el
primer país del mundo en introducir el
bit cohen como dinero de curso legal en
su sistema monetario muchos salvadoreños
tienen poca confianza en la cripta
moneda principalmente por la falta de
información otros países como panamá y
cuba- también buscan reconocer este tipo
de activos
pero así se prepara este martes para las
manifestaciones convocadas por
seguidores del presidente revolucionario
en el día de la independencia las
protestas a favor del mandatario quieren
también rechazar la decisión de la corte
suprema que investiga a políticos que
propagan noticias falsas también habrá
marchas en contra del mandatario
los talibanes continúan reclamando la
conquista de la provincia norteña de
panshir la única región del país que no
ha estado en manos de los extremistas
entre tantos cientos de instalaciones
médicas en afganistán podrían cerrar
esta semana porque los donantes
occidentales que los financian se niegan
a negociar con el grupo talibán
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 si revelan que para mí como
siempre es un placer acompañarlos
comenzamos en el salvador que este
martes se convierte en el primer país
del mundo en darle curso legal al
bitcoin como moneda legal al entrar en
vigor una nueva ley que permite la
circulación de la cripto moneda según
diversas encuestas esto ha generado
rechazo en muchos salvadoreños que
anuncian protestas y se prevé
incertidumbre en las próximas semanas
nuestro corresponsal en san salvador
blaine el samur nos amplia al respecto
el zonte es una pequeña comunidad
costera famosa por la fuerza de sus olas
pero en 2019 la oleada de bitcoin
cambiaría para siempre el destino de
esta concurrida playa somos los primeros
en el país que empezó bitcoin somos
quienes sembramos la semilla ahora el
mundo entero tiene sus ojos sobre el
salvador
esa semilla nació por un donante anónimo
quien decidió patrocinar con bitcoins
los proyectos sociales que jorge lidera
desde casa esperanza con una sola
condición impulsar a una economía basada
en la cripta moneda
kvitko ya ha sido el programa más
emblemático que el país ha tenido como
lo dijo el presidente tomamos la copia
del sostén de bitcoin beach es cesante
lo logró lo puede lograr el país
pronto la ola se extendió y 200 cajeros
automáticos dedicados a la cripta divisa
han sido instalados en todo el país el
pequeño negocio de orlando está más que
listo para este nuevo momento
todos estamos esperando bajar la ual y
para dar el impulso sin embargo algunas
personas ya vinieron y me ha dicho va a
aceptar because ya estoy listo
el gobierno ha ofrecido el equivalente a
30 dólares en bitcoin a quienes
descarguen el archivo valet la billetera
electrónica oficial en su celular pero
el incentivo no ha sido suficiente para
romper la apatía dentro de la población
no estoy preparada para usar este
bitcoin yo digo que hay mucha gente no
solo yo que en vez de andamos telefonía
gente que ni ni teléfono ni como usar un
teléfono porque tienen que haber dado
este primero este mucha orientación
verdad pero no importa que haya entrado
ya porque realmente no vamos a entrar de
lleno todo va entre los economistas la
alta volatilidad del bitcoin es la
principal objeción cuando nosotros
estamos pasando de mercados seguros
digamos de transacciones seguras que se
efectúan a mercados especulativos
estamos poniendo a la economía realmente
en una situación bastante
compleja diga el salvador es el primer
país del mundo en dar curso legal a la
cripta moneda el tiempo de gracia el
plan futurista de replicar el
experimento del son t eso no el camino
para dinamizar la economía real
vamos hasta brasil donde miles de
personas salen a las calles para
manifestarse el día de su fiesta
nacional se espera una jornada de
atención con protestas a favor y en
contra del presidente yair bolsonaro
ante esto y ante la petición del
mandatario habrá un gran despliegue de
seguridad para evitar desmanes y
enfrentamientos entre tanto visionario y
todo un decreto que prohíbe a las
empresas de redes sociales quitar
contenidos según él de forma arbitraria
los brasileños también salen a las
calles para rechazar la minería dentro
de las áreas de conservación que creció
un 300 por ciento en todo el país y casi
un 500 por ciento dentro de las tierras
indígenas
como presidente de brasil
yaír bolsonaro está a la cabeza de uno
de los países más biodiversos del
planeta y justamente el tema de la
protección de dicha biodiversidad es uno
de los que más críticas le vale la
minería dentro de las áreas de
conservación creció un 300 por ciento en
todo el país y casi un 500 por ciento
dentro de hechuras indígenas con una
aceleración estos últimos años según más
idiomas una investigación en la que
colaboraron una red de ong universidades
y empresas de tecnología esto no son
dentales duran observamos a un daño
irreversible al medio ambiente como
consecuencia de la minería ilegal de
hecho es muy difícil que la naturaleza
se recupere de ello incluso con la
intervención humana también el mercurio
que se utiliza la extracción trae
consigo otros problemas de salud pública
especialmente para quienes viven en las
orillas del río y en la población
indígena menciones gp niños y
poblaciones indígenas los mineros dicen
no tener otras formas de ingresos y
depositan todas sus esperanzas en el
proyecto de ley que el presidente
bolsonaro mandó al congreso para abrir
las reservas indígenas a la minería
comercial
no hay empleo
no hay buenas empresas dentro del estado
para ti la semana pasada miles de
indígenas acamparon en brasilia en
protesta por lo que consideran la agenda
anti indígena del presidente y marcharon
hacia el tribunal supremo que está
analizando actualmente un caso clave
sobre sus derechos a sus tierras
ancestrales
además tras la llegada de bolsonaro al
poder brasil ha registrado el mayor
ritmo de deforestación de los últimos 13
años la delegación del gobierno
venezolano en conversaciones con la
oposición anunció anoche los dos o
primeros acuerdos parciales en la
segunda fase de negociaciones que se
realizan en la ciudad de mexico el
primero es la ratificación y ensa la
soberanía de venezuela sobre la guyana
esequiba un territorio que el país
reclama suyo desde el siglo 19 y el
segundo acuerdo es la recuperación de
los activos que se encuentran
depositados en cuentas en el extranjero
los secretarios de estado y de defensa
de eeuu anthony blinken y lloyd austin
se evaluaron en doha la situación en
afganistán tras la retirada de sus
tropas se reunieron con el emir de qatar
al que agradecieron sus esfuerzos para
la evacuación de ciudadanos
estadounidenses del país asiático según
el departamento de estado estadounidense
más de 55 mil evacuados afganos han sido
enviados a qatar que está sirviendo como
parada transitoria antes de continuar su
viaje la unión americana
doha acoge desde hace años una oficina
política de los talibanes y ha ejercido
como mediador en las negociaciones de
paz
y cientos de instalaciones médicas en
afganistán podrían cerrar esta semana
porque los donantes occidentales que los
financian se niegan a negociar con las
autoridades del grupo talibán la
organización mundial de la salud lanzó
la alerta aseguran que intentan paliar
la situación mediante el envío de
suministros de equipamiento y
financiación para 500 centros de salud
donantes incluyendo el banco mundial la
unión europea ue se suspendieron su
financiación regular a afganistán porque
no pueden enviar fondos por medio de las
autoridades talibanas la organización
mundial de la salud alerta que como
resultado más de 2300 instalaciones
médicas afganas cerrarían en cuestión de
días
según algunas estimaciones cerca del 90%
probablemente dejarán de funcionar a lo
largo de esta semana algo que podría
conllevar un aumento de las enfermedades
y las defunciones y un retroceso de los
enormes progresos de los últimos 20 años
si los cierres perdurase a la o ms
asegura que espera enviar material
médico por vía aérea próximamente el
objetivo es lograr que 500 centros
médicos permanezcan abiertos
esperamos que llegue uno de los vuelos
del programa mundial de alimentos que
esta semana amasar
y el gobierno de qatar también nos
ofreció ayuda y esperamos que mande
entre dos o tres cargos con suministros
probablemente a kabul estas semanas
y
el personal de la salud afgana protesto
la semana pasada en kabul pidiendo a la
comunidad internacional que mantenga su
ayuda financiera asegurando que millones
de afganos corren el riesgo de quedarse
sin atención médica y que 26.000
trabajadores médicos incluyendo 7500
mujeres podrían perder sus empleos y de
esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día para todos ya nos
vemos
[Música]
y si bien se me deja muy bien
edison